and peter look it's hard for us to
complain because
we get something that we can just talk
about all day long and good or bad the
the aftermath of the packers lions game
is going to be a dominant topic now i
don't know that this is the kind of
topic the nfl wants to dominate but
we're talking about we could be talking
about baseball we could be talking about
what lebron james said last night we're
going to be talking about what happened
at lambeau field
well and i'm sure that roger goodell is
going to be talking about what happened
at lambeau field when he convenes the
nfl owners in fort lauderdale today for
a
day and a half meeting uh to discuss the
league issues there's really nothing big
on this agenda the only thing they're
going to talk about much is
you know other than officiating because
that is on the agenda i mean they're
obviously going to talk about the cba
and where they stand now two years out
or a year and three quarters out
but mike i i think what is incumbent
upon the league right now
um is is to basically say that
at this point
is is the way we designed
uh officiating is the way we designed it
does this work
should there be what the coaches voted
32 to nothing
now should we take a serious look
at basically mining
and finding
17 sky judges so that they can look down
on the field and so that they could say
wait a second trey flowers did not put
hands to the face on that play and we
have to do something about it maybe not
you're not going to do something about
it in the middle of this season but as
you see him right here come around the
corner you see that he did not put a
hand to the face
and how that pla how that is is not seen
and seen incorrectly
that is why the coaches want the sky
judge that's exactly why because they
want an insurance policy and these two
calls last night late in this game are a
great example of why that sky judge and
the development
of people to be those sky judges should
be strongly considered by the nfl yeah i
hear you peter all the way i mean this
is something you know my man mike florio
has been saying really since the debacle
in new orleans last year and i got to
give him a lot of credit he's been all
over this and uh i think you know we've
seen enough this year that i'm i'm on
board i think this might be something
that has to be done you know in these
situations it's just hey there's too
many people's lives careers money uh
things like that legacies are all at
stake in these type of moments and yeah
they were bad calls now i just take this
it's just interesting to me and again
they were messed calls i'm not trying to
make excuses or anything like that it is
you know i wonder if this is going to be
one of those things that they go back
and look at after the year's over and
maybe make it illegal to have like your
hand in the horse collar department of
an offense alignment you know trey
flowers looked like he was deliberately
doing that now it's not against the
rules so there's nothing wrong with it i
just find that fascinating as well
but either way it's just not a good look
for the nfl right now there's been too
much conversation about officiating
through the first six weeks of the
season and it's taking away from hey
we're not talking right now to start the
show about a performance we saw from
aaron rodgers that was phenomenal last
night or a defense in green bay that did
a lot of great things uh instead we're
talking about you know some bad bad
calls by by the zebras
the biggest problem the league has right
now is that gap between what the
officials see on the field as they're
trying primarily peter to not get
trampled and what the rest of us see at
home in the highest available technology
crystal clear we all know what happened
to bridge that gap with a member of the
officiating crew peter i i assume that
as you use the term sky judge you're
using it the way i use it as it is a
member of the crew put that person in
black and white stripes they are an
equal member of the crew and it's no
different than the meetings that we see
on the field when officials talk to each
other you're just having someone in the
booth who was talking directly to the
referee saying pick up the flag drop the
flag this is what happened this is what
everybody at home sees happened we need
to bridge that gap so people aren't
outraged
mike one of the reasons why one the
first time
that this was seriously considered at
the league meetings last year when the
coaches informally voted 32 to nothing
to install a sky judge the first thing
when i mention this to somebody
in the league i said hey what about this
sky judge thing
one of the things in the first
conversation i had
was
where are we going to get the sky judges
are we going to take for instance are we
going to take
some officials from the field
and put them in the booth then we're
going to have to replace say a back
judge a line judge a down judge are we
going to do that
so
there was concern right away
in late march
saying well wait a second how are we
going to find 17 of these of these
people to get on these crews right now
however
i'm going to say this right now if you
know
that this is something that you're
strongly considering
this is something that the nfl when it
scouts officials okay you just scout
officials in college football at the
highest level of college football and
you say okay we may need a few more of
these this year we may be replacing more
of these officials because we're going
to be moving some of our game officials
into the booth into those important
positions and i don't know how they
would do it but the fact is it's october
now there's plenty of time to do this
for 2020 and if you are going to have an
advanced form of replay as the nfl does
more and more replay i think the sky
judge is a good way to go especially
after seeing the debacle last night easy
solution easy solution
dean blandino mike pereira john perry
terry mccauley gene sterritor ad hocule
former officials some of whom are now
making good money in tv you offer them
more money to be sky judges and i think
it's a perfect position for an older
official who maybe is concerned about
hips and knees and running around out
there among the gladiators you still
have the benefit of the brain you have
the benefit of the experiences you have
the benefit of the eyesight you have the
benefit of the understanding of the
rules those are the people who need to
be paid accordingly these are important
jobs you know i remember dean blandino
telling me chris a couple of years ago
after he left the nfl for fox that the
nfl doesn't value the position of vp of
officiating the way it should what
doesn't value any of the officiating
positions the way it should this comes
down to how much money are you willing
to spend and the answer that question is
more i am glad you went there because
that's where i wanted to go i mean if
you want more quality officials and
people that are qualified for the job
make it more lucrative for people to
want to do it and then they can pass the
series of tests and things they need to
do to be an official i mean that's one
thing that comes to my mind right away
and i think you both made great points
i'm totally on board with that but yeah
they need to make it more lucrative to
to where yeah some people who might be
on the fence who are qualified for the
job go damn you know what i got to do it
for that kind of money 17 day games a
year and i know there's more to it than
that
i'm going to jump into it i'll say
another thing that i i think of and i've
said this before in my podcast
i think the nfl should get more
ex-players involved in officiating on
the field level i do i do think at times
you know and again i know the referees
have a really tough job and i'm not
certainly trying not to take anything
away from it but i do think the game has
become so fierce and explosive and the
guys are so big and it's moved so fast
the speed of the game at times is a
little too fast for some of these guys
who you know are lawyers and then all of
a sudden you know it comes fall time and
they're around football players all the
time just something i think about i'm
not saying i'm right or wrong there but
it's just another angle i look at to
maybe help correct this situation
wouldn't that be a great cause
wouldn't that be great look i mean
actually
yeah yeah
there are plenty of guys out there who
have the fitness and the experience that
they can be good officials yeah
peter i i think that i think that's a
good idea but i want to go back to one
thing you said mike i i'm just going to
throw out this right now i mean probably
the the top salary for a referee right
now in football i'm going to guess is
around
280 to 300 and that is a guess that's a
guess
but in my opinion
all these guys right now who are going
to tv are probably making more than 300
000
to make the move to go to tv probably
making four to five hundred thousand and
again that's a guess also
but i guess my biggest point about this
mike is do you value the sky judge as
being a more important person on a crew
than the referee than the crew chief
i personally don't
but i understand why some people might
but i don't know how then you would pay
the sky judge
say 60 or 80 percent more
than the guys who are on the field in
order to entice them from a tv job and
and i should pay everybody the solution
is paying everybody a lot more yeah but
i i don't i don't see them doing that
they're going to make billions
billions off of legalized gambling in
various forms and fashions now they've
made billions over the years off of
illegal gambling but as legalized
gambling spreads peter this is the
ultimate thing the nfl needs to be
concerned about when you have
unsatisfying outcomes like last night
and when there are 40 or 45 states that
have legalized gambling and if you do
have an outcome where the point spread
and the outcome of the bet and the over
and the under anything like that
millions of dollars swings on a bad call
that's when you have to worry about
congress eventually saying we're going
to look into what the hell's going on
with the nfl's officiating and and
that's why they need to peel off some of
that money some of those billions and
value these positions more and i think
every position that is devoted to
officiating needs to get more money i
just think that across the board the
budget needs to be bigger and there
needs to be more money available i think
referees shouldn't be making 280 they
should be making 880 they should be
making 780. they should be making at
least as much as the veteran minimum for
a player they're out there among the
players guys agreed and under tremendous
scrutiny as we know and it's not an easy
job you know gosh you know even you know
players can you know
at times the you know you think you see
one thing and you know oh it wasn't that
you know when you go back and see it on
tv or so even some of those guys who who
have been around the sport and all that
are going to mess up some calls at times
or what they saw on the field it's a
very tough job and it's under a
microscope and uh i do think that's
really the biggest thing they got to
make it more enticing pay these guys
more money and like i said i'd like to
see a few ex players involved too
because i don't think they'll be
overwhelmed by the moment i don't think
they'll be bullied by players in certain
situations i don't think they'll give a
damn about what the fans think either
and i think those are positive things as
well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports